no you should have told is that Chinese
guy that went to God get you which
Chinese guy there's no one that the guy
that you did an impression of right time
you know what he would have said can I
eat him now that was my wife is my
girlfriend's mother I do a joke if I do
a joke and it doesn't work you wanna do
that face like that but it's a dog
eating one will cut it out it's the same
way like you don't like we eat they have
a dog eating trade in Korea as they do
in China and the Philippines sure yeah
absolutely
what I want to say to you Michael is it
just talking to you for this brief
moment yes I hate guy I've gotten a lot
of feelings yeah you do I'm trying to
hide them
yeah I'm hiding one I know I'm failing
me too
I'm doing but what I want to say to you
is that a years ago I did a there was
just this MMA awards show that Randy
Couture hosted okay right I don't know
why this is no you know I'm gonna tell
you and he was [ __ ] terrible I think
that Randy gets her is a legend but why
the [ __ ] would I don't know what up on
stage like a [ __ ] Frankenstein right
and he had no personality but you
honestly I feel that you could probably
do not that I want you to or you
wouldn't but you could even do comedy I
think Stan yeah a lot of people say yeah
I think I could do it Brendon did it and
he's successful now I I don't want to
force you to do anything that you don't
want to do but you are charismatic you
look much and you're just a you're some
funny guy well thank you that's very
kind
yeah yeah you know people do same strong
to you for amazing because because you
know when you look at you you think no
straw buyer you look past that yeah you
look past the exterior see what's on the
inside why and there's still nothing
now of course she's strong though yeah
yeah no I appreciate that
I appreciate that since I've been doing
my podcast believe you may check it out
people yeah yeah you know we get a lot
of good
what's a coffee but believe you me
believe you mean anyway sleepers listen
to me
you gotta check it out it's checkout
Michael Bisping 'he's podcasts believe
you me and and and believe me to you
mmm that it is gonna be you're gonna
love it it's okay it's great it's
alright I can already tell it's great
it's okay yeah we have fun have you done
Rogen's podcast I have yeah did it about
a month ago yeah I get intimidated by
him oh really a little bit why because
because he's an alpha male and and any
you know yeah I mean he's not just that
is it that when I started doing comedy
was already a headliner of course so I
just have this you know you know when I
see guys like him or you know older guys
like Kevin Nealon even or something like
that I just kind of have this yeah I
mean I guess I mean I think I understand
what you saying he's a respect thing
right it's a respect yeah of course it
is yeah I mean I was like that when I
first came into the UFC and those guys
that you watched like like a running
Couture or something like wow this guy's
a legend right like you know down yeah
people like that when I first came in I
was a kid you know fresh-faced you've
seen them on TV you know so there's a
little bit of that you know but I think
that's healthy so a healthy attitude to
have and and the sport you mean back in
the day that sport was the Wild West but
now it's a bona fide legitimate mmm
sport that's like it could be in the
Olympics I'll add the way like you
looked around the room telling everyone
like you were making a big announcement
yeah we know I know I'm just saying
mobile it's a global legitimate sport
that's just improving and growing and
it's elite athletes and it's just just
just an amazing we are flat to Brooklyn
on Thursday with the first ever ESPN
card yes p.m. plus cards I mean it's a
big deal you know they moved there from
class they left they announced it on the
last card not see wait wait
UFC is no longer with fog the fog
ESPN Lian money predominantly let's be
honest what they don't did they weren't
making money I don't get no no no they
were making money so I mean come on
you're in the entertainment you know you
know you know how it works you know they
pay for rights Fox pays UFC for price I
sell to the highest bidder
yeah ESPN came in with a massive RS 1.5
billion for five years right yeah and
and Fox wasn't willing to match that
public information yeah they went to
ESPN which is excited for myself excited
for everyone involved with the sport
certainly is the next logical
progression for the sport no disrespect
to Fox Sports they were an amazing
platform AZ helped bring the sport to a
whole nother level
you really did you know but yeah but the
SPN is the top yeah it's the [ __ ] top
right now
here's the one thing when Reebok took
over right did you like that
no because you kind of lost you kind of
lost people yeah you know yeah yeah I
get it
so um how well we had time Michael
Bisping over an hour I can't [ __ ]
believe it
it's crazy it's crazy we don't we're not
n done we're almost done though but I
got the end my drag me all this way okay
for a [ __ ] hour
yeah took me long ago not to drive here
not to mention the three and a half
hours sound very cold sandwich it's your
[ __ ] fault that you live in Orange
County tell you to move to Orange County
[ __ ] no but what you did was yeah I do
you know you very with you little [ __ ]
[ __ ] little gang I want to see this
going back roll with it I love you
thank you I do thank you I deeply love
appreciate it
my can it be forever my can it be
forever I'm well I'm gonna see if what
we can do let him guess for you before I
show if you ever did stand yeah Michael
oh yeah
just hear me out I'm hearing you because
I play the Irvine improv and places in
February in February are you gonna be
there yeah honestly I'm not just saying
this because I'm here with you me and my
wife we came my wife and I yeah we
laughed our [ __ ] asses off I swear to
god it was so funny that night yeah yeah
it was incredible it really was I
laughed my face was hurting it was it
was we've been trying to see you ever
since well I I met that Ravana Empire in
February right if you wanted to do time
you could do it I've got a show coming
up in Toronto but it's not like stand-up
but it's gonna be funny yeah yeah it's
like a one-man show yeah yeah but if you
ever have the itch never ever wanted a
time in front of a crowd the thing is
but I can be you know in my humble
opinion I could be so more entertaining
in a platform like this or in a setting
like this doing a set you gotta sit down
you're gonna write that I'm more off the
top of my head you know what I'm saying
you're gonna write Joe no no extreme of
conscience yeah yeah no no no because
there's just justifications because of
the fear no absolutely you're walking
into an arena that you're uncomfortable
with you know which does excite me if
I'm honest you know I do like to test
myself a challenge myself I can't
imagine what it would be like to enter
the Octagon especially in a big night
you know what's a big card in that
thrill that you get you know I can't
imagine that I'm sure it's something
that I'll never experience but you know
I think stand-up you would get a similar
feeling I'm sure it is I'm sure there's
no better feeling than going out there
if you got a packed house and making
everyone piss their pants laughing yeah
sure it's amazing yeah you know and and
it's probably very similar because you
know you as a comic that's your passion
that's you love that's what you aspire
to do so when you're succeeding in that
joy as a fighter same thing you know
we're trying to win we're trying to get
ahead we're trying to succeed so so you
know it in many ways they're very
similar you know that's what Gomes my
Lussier Gomes my podcast partner he says
the same thing there's a lot of
similarities between being a fire and a
comedian you know if you break it down
[Music]